what's going on guys this is Rob we're
going to postpone our Fantastic Four
video until next week because in this
video we're covering the origin of Mr
Immortal so this guy's had a tragic life
man this guy's had a very tragic life so
the idea behind this is that when Craig
Hollis was born he was introduced to two
things the first was the concept of
death and the second was basically death
urge now the idea behind this and death
urge is really really murky right we'll
talk about him here in a second but the
idea behind this is that Craig's mom
basically died during childbirth and so
that's why he's sort of introduced to
death by way of his mom basically
passing on as well as the concept or the
being named death urge now again one of
the things he talks about is that as a
baby he didn't fully understand
everything that's going on it's a little
weird because he recalls more than a
baby normally would uh but death urge is
a very very murky character right a very
mysterious character in Marvel Comics
it's one of these things that Marvel
introduced as a way to sort of justify
the purpose of death or how death Works
in Marvel Comics more than anything else
but the idea behind this is that death
urge is what you might refer to as the
Grim Reaper in the sense that when a
person dies death urge appears and death
urge whisks that person away to
basically the afterlife the realm of
mistress death summing along those lines
and of course that's where death urge
takes the mom of Craig Hollis but it was
one of those circumstances where because
death urge was present Craig would just
never die and so like literally there'd
be instances where like they're doing
patty cake in the street or like he's in
a tree during an electric storm and like
he just never dies and so Marvel never
really gives us a concrete answer Marvel
never really defines if Craig always
survived these experiences because it's
his power to basically push death urge
away so death urge can never actually
take him or if it's simply that death
urge kept him out of situations where he
would die like he protected him from
Death because that's one of the things
you remember death urge doesn't actually
kill you it's just the circumstances
that kill you and then death urge takes
you away but all in all one of the
things that happens is that death urge
is has really kind of like a influence
went on Craig where for example he
actually kind of goads him into playing
with fire and then when they do or at
least when he does it sets the house on
fire and that his dad is ultimately
killed and his dad is taken away by
death Earth and it's one of those things
where where we would kind of look at the
situation and say okay like death or
just protecting him one of the things
that happened is that where his father's
being taken away and he's crying out the
response of death urge is it's your time
Edward right it's your time to die and
it's like no no right your son will
always have me like I'll always keep
your son protected so again it's a
little strange and a little murky but
the importance behind this is that
because of this relationship between
death urge and Mr Immortal that he just
doesn't die right he's just it's
impossible for him to die and so with
the death of his father he's basically
taken to a foster home where his foster
father just beats the crap out of him
all the time but also abuses another one
of the foster kids named Terry and so
there's a kind of bond that forms
between the two of them where they start
off as friends and then they eventually
become lovers and so they ultimately end
up escaping the house and then there
comes a point point where they're
literally living ragtag now the whole
thing behind this is like they have each
other and that's really the only thing
that matters so no matter how bad things
get
um they'll always end up being together
but the reality here and it's something
that that's a little murky is that Terry
basically leaves a note for Craig and
then we never really find out what
happens next we will later on uh but we
never find out in that moment what
happened to her all we know is she
basically left the picture and so I
really like with his heart broken and
having experienced nothing but a life of
pain Craig goes to kill himself right
like jumps off a building and goes to do
himself in smashes into the ground and
then gets up right and literally just
heals and so it's one of those things
where like literally this life he lives
is one of just torment and pain and all
he wants to do is end it so there's a
point where he blows himself up with
dynamite he tries to drown himself he
drinks bleach now he does all kinds of
things but every single time he always
survives and he always heals he never
actually dies and so as a result of that
he comes to this realization that this
idea of his life being one of Torment is
really just in his head because he comes
to this Revelation okay if I can never
really die then basically I can be a
superhero right like I mean sure I can't
like fly and I don't have super strength
or anything along those lines but
there's got to be somewhere in the
superhero community that I can fit into
so he ends up crafting a name for
himself called Mr Immortal it makes
perfect sense and on his first outing he
basically tries to stop these guys
wearing Spider-Man masks who are robbing
a jewelry store and as soon as he shows
up they shoot him in the face and like
he dies
well he doesn't officially die right
like these guys basically make their
escape and then of course he heals and
he gets back up but that's when he
realizes okay like I can't really do
this on my own I need a team so what he
ends up doing is basically reaching out
to other Misfit superheroes flat man Big
Bertha and so on and he forms the Great
Lakes Avengers now it's kind of a side
track here we're not gonna go super in
depth into this when it came to the
Avengers teams in Marvel Comics you do
have like the main Avengers and
different variations of it so you've got
the Avengers and then you have the new
Avengers team that was formed when the
original Avengers team disbanded during
Avengers disassemble and then after New
Avengers you had the mighty Avengers and
you had like all kinds of teams Young
Avengers and so on and so forth the
Great Lakes Avengers are those are those
are like the cast stops right the Island
of Misfit Toys the kids that just don't
fit in anywhere right that's that's the
Great Lakes Avengers and it was always
just kind of a goofy team but it was
never a serious comic it was like if you
could take the concept of Deadpool and
turn him into an Avengers team it's the
Great Lakes Avengers basically what it
is even though Deadpool I don't think
was ever really on the team although I
think he did team up with them a few
times but the thing about this is that
him being on the team is kind of funny
because one of the things that happened
is they ended up getting a member called
leather boy who of course has no powers
and basically leather boy thought that
it was just kind of like a BDSM thing
right they were getting together for
that kind of stuff uh but ultimately the
team had outings and they do have their
own comic lines that have been going on
for years leading up to this particular
story and they were okay right depending
on on what your thing is and what kind
of stuff you like but the kicker about
all this is that for Craig himself one
of the revelations that we end up
learning is that the team ends up going
against the villain by the name of
maelstrom now Maelstrom was a pretty
significant villain this guy was was
hugely powerful this guy was like an
Avengers level threat right like a World
level threat he was really really
capable but basically death urge where
he hadn't appeared for quite some time
which again seems to point to the idea
that Craig's powers are tied less to
death urge keeping him protected and
tied more to the fact that he literally
just can't die which is why death third
seemed to have an interest in him that
what it does is it leads to death urge
reappearing here and that's when you
kind of get this Revelation that what
Craig had thought had happened is that
when it came to Terry the note she had
left behind was a suicide note that she
had ended her own life and the belief of
Craig was that dethard had goaded her
into doing it the reality here is that
for Terry herself she just couldn't
stand the life that she lived anymore
and it was less about the life she had
with Craig and it was more about just
the past experience that she had in her
own life that it just haunted her right
like the abuse she sustained at the
hands of her of her father right there
the adopted father she had all those
things it just created nothing but a
series of problems and a result of that
is she really just had PTSD is what it
seemed like she never fully recovered
and she took her life because of it and
so that's one of the reasons why if you
go back and you read the old Great Lakes
Avengers stories that you actually dealt
with the idea of Craig just kind of
casting off and pushing away death urge
and not want to have anything to do with
him considering him a Tormentor more
than anything else hence the reason why
he had disappeared for quite some time
but that's basically the origin right
that's basically the origin of of Mr and
more right a guy that just cannot die he
like literally there's an Incredible
Hulk story in Immortal Hulk where he
survives to the end of the universe he's
like the last living thing in the
universe so it's impossible for him to
die it just simply doesn't happen which
really begs the question when the
universe ends what happens to him but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace